thank you hello welcome to
our press room today is
wednesday december 16th
[Music]
for the title all blacks
do everything that pilots a week
thank you steam then I still want to
remind you that executive vice president
valley dark  auspices and
commissioner paulo de jeunes whom he hates
will participate in the meeting of
the eurogroup which is being held by
videoconference this afternoon the
ministers will discuss the
macroeconomic situation and opinions on the
draft budgetary plans that the
commission presented in  november a
press conference with the commissioner
a pylon will take place there after the meeting
finally the fisheries ministers are
holding a meeting today at
which commissioner jean 5 and vitus
represent the
commission of ministers discuss in
particular the fishing possibilities for
the year  next the commissioner will
participate there also in the
press conference this evening and with this we are
pr  are to take your questions and I will
immediately pass the floor to mauzé
mauzé yes if no action is
taken which purges the wifi network the
daniel indices as well as the allocation to the
old cohen cellars
daniel mach sauce our weekends djimou
ida so  what we move to david yes thank you
Eric I hope you can hear me I'm trying
to laugh about it yes I want to put my camera into play
thank you very much it's still on
the vaccination I wanted to have more
details about the announcement this morning
from the president
if I understood correctly authorization
expected in the next few weeks and
above all more details if possible on
the fact that all the member states will
start together on the same day and if I
can already add a question is
what  you have received all the
national vaccination strategies the national vaccination plans
do you think that all member states
are ready for this very
difficult task as the president
of a  arrive at a vaccination of 70% of the
population thank you thank you delicious the
second question I will pass the floor
to stéphane but on the first what
I can say is that president
founder hate has emphasized in
the European parliament today  that the
commission is ready to
actively support a start a start of
vaccination at the same time in all
member states as was discussed
at the european council last week
and the commission
strongly encourages a coordinated approach to
vaccination from the moment when  a
vaccine will have been declared safe and
effective it is desirable that the
vaccination begins as soon as possible
on the basis of the vaccination strategies
that you have that you have
mentioned
and therefore what is clear is
that if the European agency for
medicines gives its authorization
after the meeting where its
positive recommendation rather after the meeting of the 21st
the commission will make sure to be able to
give the au  authorization for the
marketing of which the two days and it is
in permanent contact with the
member states to help them prepare
to launch the vaccination phase
as quickly as possible
I will pass the floor to stéphane on your
second question yes thank you thank you
very much  david i don't think there is
much i can add to what
eric has already put in as far as
you know david we have received input
from member states on the preparation of
their campaign and their
vaccination plan  the high schools here as you
know to write a report with an overview
of the state of the matter an overview of the
steps and actions that have been
taken earlier by the member states
in several areas with
regard for example to the  identification
of the main priorities the preparation
of infrastructures etc
we remain in contact with the
member states and as was
also indicated in our communication
of mid October we are ready  é to
help support member states with
the preparation of their vaccination of
their vaccination phase
because indeed as eric has just
said we will want to start it is
important that we can start our
vaccinations our vaccination campaigns
as soon as possible  possible
thank you very much thank you stéphane mauzé
had a question that i'm going to read
since we have problems with
his microphone with dosing manias world of
marseille steve in the coming months
stéphane distinguin a formation of
commissions know a context where
she lives with cyndi lauper while him in
giving their dose of aid knb divalto i
want corse and support a debt of 5 go
back to danielle soucy all this is over
august daniel ryan hawke is what
you hear now we hear
perfectly go ahead ok thank you thank you
very much excuse me for yes  i just have
a flop for david you said that the
commission will encourage a start at the
same time how can we
imagine  that in practice what is
the commission going to do concretely
and is a start on the same day
really realistic let us say what the
member states we know that they are not
all at the same time of the preparation
is this  that it is realistic to have a
start really or even day thank you thank you
I pass the floor back to stéphane
thank you very much
in fact so I can add
something to what eric has just said what
is important is that we have c
is this the start of these
vaccinations as
soon as possible as soon as possible following the delivery
of delivery of these vaccines which the
commission remains at the disposal of
the member states to help them with the
preparation
what we have done  we are of the opinion
that a coordinated approach to these
vaccinations
the most is the most important in order to be
able to start moving on to this
very important phase
thank you thank you we remain on the issue
of accents and I have kathimerini yanis
exchange of l  their protection is to
contact two companies had run away
fortis vaccinate their animals heat
xive blocked all the same on stand by and
population which suffers from studios sony
pictures and ferrières didot does not come out of
this vaccination
david killed again a question on the
subject yes it  is on the
distribution key if I may I had already asked
the question in the past but perhaps
today we can have a
more precise answer
because since the Member States
are not all at the same level of  near
ration does it make sense to
distribute vaccines to countries that
are not ready to inoculate the doses
they will receive and not to give these
doses to countries that are more advanced
so could speed up the
vaccination campaign thank you  stéphane
yes thank you david I can only dream
laugh what lies in our
acquired vaccine strategy a let's start from the
principle and the fact of the finding
rather than the the virus is present in
all member states in the same
way we have the virus in the north
in the south in the east and in the west
of our continent and therefore it is for
this reason that a distribution of the
vaccine on the basis of the  population is a
justification is a pop and a
fair distribution that allows all
member states to have this
correct distribution
so we continue to use this this
criterion which has also been recognized is
welcomed as the whole
air vaccine strategy by
member states and so it is on this
basis that we are working thank you
thomazo yes hello thank you it is
only a question on vaccines
because the meeting of elements on
vaccines from pfizer in paris tech was
anticipated to expectations and in  december and
i would like to know if these long ones where it
will be possible to also anticipate the street
union and elements and who say ah
i have spoken all since january on
modern vaccines
thank you very much but i believe  that you
must have called yourself bad institutions
you have to have a question to the
european medicines agency
it is she who decides
when she is ready
to hold her meeting on the basis of the
elements  information they
have so I think you
should address your question to him at the
European
Medicines Agency are there any other questions for us
today on the vaccines thomaes can you
hear me eric yes yes yes yes  I
understand the political pressure to
have an authorization also in
europe as soon as possible before the end of
the year but what you are not afraid of a
little what is going to happen is
that we are starting to have  side
effects of the cases and all the novak
often jumped on the first
problem to show that vaccines
are not good and there is going to be a huge
controversy over it what does
anyone say what do you think
of all this in the end  pressure that  i go
up to win for the race against
the clock but that's thank you everything is fine i
think it is absolutely essential to
remember that it is up to the
european medicines agency to decide
when it wants to think it will
be able to  give its
favorable opinion for a vaccine and that from
the moment it has done so, it will be
according to the procedure that it has put in
place, as we say in English, like
market gutters in the elections and
therefore that would mean that all the
guarantees have been respected with
regard to the procedure and therefore that the
liability issues that you
mentioned will be settled according to
this according to this procedure
here is the European Medicines
Agency itself published a press release yesterday
in  which she explained
that it was the developments which
had allowed her to bring forward the date of the ddt
the meeting is obviously we have
no other comment to
make on it except  t to rejoice, of
course, that we can all move forward
together perhaps a little
bit faster than what was
initially planned in the development
of the vaccine in europe
I no longer see any other questions for
us on health issues
y  are there any other questions for us
today the ornais of the un will do everything
[Music]
anatolia
the madness of bearing everything a debt to
the man said all his satisfaction one
of our lives the date of china for
anna andy will be broadcast from 2010